alors michel serrault ministre de
l'intérieur jean louis trintignant
président de la république michel
auclair un journaliste un peu trouble
hippolyte girardot un jeune homme qui
met le feu aux poudres en volant une
lettre d'amour c'est exact tout ça sans
effet et dans l'histoire devient celle
de claire oui leclerc d'un autre
personnage que l'on voit au bout d'un
moment ce moment gym d'un enfant est en
fait c'est surtout l'histoire de trois
personnages qui se sont connus il ya dix
ans qui se retrouvent dans des
circonstances assez assez pas
dramatiquement bas disons assez assez
grave
comme ce sont des gens qui ne se sont
pas revus depuis longtemps tout ce qui
ne se disent pas éteint et qui a pas du
tout de flashbacks dans le film tout ce
qui ne se disent pas et presque plus
important que ce qu'ils vont se dire
alors sans enfant sans déflorer histoire
disons quand même que claire a eu un
enfant d'un monsieur qui est au moment
du film président de la république et
cela devient une affaire d'état à partir
du moment où l'on découvre une lettre
qui prouvent ces faits qui ont été tenus
cachés pour la bonne conduite de la
carrière politique de du président en
question
je rectifie au moment où elle connut cet
homme il était en politique il n'était
pas président de la république c'est
cela catherine deneuve vous êtes-vous
fasciné par le pouvoir dans les hommes
politiques n'ont pas vraiment fasciné
les palm os et le pouvoir non plus c'est
une question qu'on m'a déjà posé avant
même que je fasse ce film alors je lui
j'en suis désolé non non non je veux
dire par là sur le le pouvoir la notion
de pouvoir ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup
mais c'est vrai que les acteurs ont
toujours dans la vie une situation un
peu un peu particulière un peu
privilégiés ils ont toujours un une
forme de pouvoir quand même donc
j'essaye de ne pas en abuser mais je
crois que les acteurs en ont un peu et
voilà cet îlot ce qu'ils entrent dans ce
film on sent bien que françois giroux
qui a donc fait le scénario et français
giro qui en est le réalisateur ont pris
bien soin d'eux
de ne pas pousser à la caricature on est
ce qu'on ne reconnaît en fait personne
ou si ce n'était pas le but but c'était
quand même le fait que ce sont des
personnages importants et des
personnages politiques rend cette
situation personnelle
évidemment plus intrigante plus forte
plus intéressantes mais le but n'était
pas de dévoiler des secrets d'état ni de
raconter des secrets d'alcôve l'idée
était de montrer des gens en politique
dans des rôles très fermé finalement et
de montrer une forme d'impuissance à
résoudre des problèmes personnels
étant donné les grands murs qui les
entoure et l'impossibilité qu'ils ont à
ne pas oublier à ne pas pouvoir oublier
toujours le rôle d'homme d'état alors ce
film est plein de non dits vous le
disiez tout à l'heure aux aînés les non
dits oui beaucoup beaucoup plus que ce
qui est dit oui c'est pour ça que c'est
pas toujours très bonne comme toi parler
alors vous vous représentez vous le
savez l'idéal féminin pour la très
grande majorité des français
alors est ce que le personnage de claire
qui paraît être une jeune femme moderne
qui s'assume comme ont commandé
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est un
personnage qui vous convient dans lequel
vous vous êtes senti à l'aise et je ne
me suis pas toujours senti à l'aise
parce que claire est une femme qui
réagit plus qu'elle n'agit c'est une
femme qui ne peut pas prendre toujours
les les choses en main d'abord parce
qu'elle est au départ dans une situation
qui n'est pas très agréable elle est
accusée et par un homme qu'elle a aimé
d'une chose qui pour l effrayante c'est
à dire d'exercer une forme
éventuellement de chantage donc elle est
déjà dans une position très difficile et
ensuite comme elle veut protéger cet
enfant à absolument
elle est dans l'opposition toujours de
se défendre donc elle n'agit pas elle
réagit et pour moi personnellement je
préfère les gens qui peuvent qui peuvent
agir
et alors le prochain rôle où l'on revoit
au cinéma une comédie une comédie une
comédie ou comédie daily show raki sagan
aussi je crois
ah oui fort saganne que j'ai déjà tourné
wii qui sortira au printemps catherine
deneuve remercie le bon plaisir donc qui
est sorti aujourd'hui dans les salles de
cinéma en france brille